字幕: Maki Numata
校正: Takako Ramsden
「志成最諦」
この言葉をご存じですか？
この言葉は 経営の神様
松下幸之助さんが作られた言葉です
志を立てたのであれば
諦めることなく 最後まで取り組むことが
大事だという意味であります
私はこの言葉と出会い
それ以後 この言葉を心に秘めて
取り組んでまいりました
1999年 当時
亀岡青年会議所の
ビジョン特別委員会のメンバーとして
20年後 2020年の
亀岡のまちの将来ビジョンを
作るために取り組みました
地域の歴史や文化資源を調査し
そして 当時の中学生 高校生に
アンケートを取ったんです
子どもたちからは 将来
この身近な自然が好きだから
「ぜひとも これを残してほしい」
「山や川の風景を大切にしてほしい」
そんな答えが返ってきたのであります
亀岡のこの答えを受けて
私たちは 亀岡の20年後の姿を
身近な自然を守り
そして 保津川の自然を大切にし
そのことが 将来の亀岡の
魅力につながると考え
20年のビジョンを
世界に誇れる
環境先進都市の実現としたのであります
そして サブタイトルに
「エコロジックミュージアムの創造」と
位置づけました
このことが 亀岡が 20年後
環境を重視して
それにより シビックプライドが高まり
合わせて 観光産業による活性化
交流人口を増やし にぎわいを創出する
そんなまちにしたいと 考えたのであります
そのことが 私の挑戦の始まりです
亀岡には 三大観光の
保津川下りがあります
この保津川は 亀岡から嵐山を通り
そして 桂川と名を変えて
そして 木津川 宇治川と合流し
淀川となり
大阪湾に流れ出る 一級河川であります
保津川下りは 416年前
京の豪商 角倉了以が開作をし
京の都へ物資を運ぶための
水運として始まりました
その後 明治28年に
観光船下りとなったのであります
そして 亀岡から嵐山までの16キロ
約１時間半で下り
四季折々の京都の自然を楽しめる
川下りとして
そして年間30万人の方が
訪れてくれています
この川に 近年 プラスチックごみが
たくさん流れ着くようになりました
観光客からは
「高いお金を払っているのに
ごみを見せるのか」
そんな言葉が投げかけられるようになり
保津川の船頭さん二人の
清掃が始まりました
そして 私たちも 有志で
「プロジェクト保津川」を立ち上げて
毎月 定例清掃会を開催しました
この定例清掃会も
今では 160回以上を超えてきました
保津川のゴミを拾い その調査をすると
レジ袋に入った食品トレイや
ペットボトルがたくさんあり
それらは ポイ捨てをされ
雨によって 川に流れ出たものが
大半であります
毎月拾っても拾っても 無くならないゴミ
「これではダメだ」
「このゴミを無くすためには
制度化が必要だ」
「まちのルールを作る必要がある」
そう考えたのであります
私は 市役所を早期退職し
そして市議会議員に出馬をし
市議会１期 府議会２期
そして 市長となり
その間 一貫して
世界に誇れる環境先進都市の実現を
掲げて取り組んでまいりました
2012年当時 府議会の折
当時の市長と共に
「海ごみサミット」の誘致に取り組みました
京都府からも 開催予算を取り付け
そして 海のない内陸部の初の自治体として
その取り組みが始まったのです
皆さんに質問いたします
海に漂う海ごみ
川から流れたものがありますが
どのぐらい川から流れていると思いますか
実は７割以上が川から流れているのです
２つ目の質問です
嵯峨嵐山から大阪湾まで 約80キロあります
嵯峨嵐山で ポイ捨てされたゴミが
大阪湾に流れ着くのは
どのぐらいだと思いますか
実は１日あれば 流れ着いてしまうのです
私たちは 海ごみサミットを
誘致するにあたり
事前に GPSのついたフロートを川に流し
そして モニタリング調査を行ないました
その結果がこの状況です
この結果から
川 海のゴミをなくすためには
内陸部から出る川ごみの発生抑制対策が
必要だということがわかったのであります
そのうち数年後
クジラや海洋生物のおなかの中から
大量のプラスチックゴミが
発見され問題になりました
2015年 市長に就任をし
今後 亀岡の埋め立て処分場を
造らないことを前提に
「亀岡ゼロエミッション計画」を策定しました
これは 2030年までに
使い捨てプラスチックを無くすまちを目指す
2018年12月 市議会とともに
「かめおかプラスチックごみゼロ宣言」を
発信をしたのであります
この目指す目標は レジ袋の有料化
そして そのうちに
プラスチックレジ袋の
提供禁止条例を作るということであります
そして 亀岡には
コンビニエンスストア
フランチャイズ店がたくさんありますが
それらの事業所が
一自治体の取り組みに協力してくれるか
高いハードルがあると感じました
しかし 私たちはこれをやらなければ
母なる川 保津川を守れない
海ごみの削減や 生物多様性
地球の環境を守ることができない
強い決意を持って 取り組むことを決めました
そして プラスチックレジ袋の
提供禁止条例を作るための
事前のレジ袋有料化を進めるため
地元の商店街連盟や スーパーマーケットに
説明会を開き 取り組みました
各事業所からは 前例のない取り組みに
躊躇と反対意見が多数を占めたのです
私たちはそれに負けず 次に
コンビニエンスストアや
ファストフード店の集まる
日本フランチャイズチェーン協会に
要望を要請し
東京に行き 挑んだ会議では
10万人も満たない一治体の取り組み
「我々は ２千店舗から３千店舗の
お店を持っている」
「それがレジ袋有料化だとか
提供禁止ができると思っているのか」
「やれるもんならやってみろ」
そんな言葉を 投げつけられたのであります
大変悔しいやら 情けないやら
そして 日本は まだまだ環境後進国だ
ということを実感しました
それと併せて この屈辱を何とか晴らしたい
その思いが
ふつふつと湧いて出たのであります
私たちは 諦めませんでした
この厳しい局面を打開するためには
事業者への継続的な協議と
市民の理解を広げる必要があるということから
2019年4月
世界に誇れる「かめおか協議会」を立ち上げ
そこには 事業者 市民
そして 学識経験者や銀行（などの）金融機関
NPO 行政が 一緒になって
一堂に会して
真剣な議論を戦わせたのであります
そして 何度か
その取り組みを進めるに当たって
一つの光が見えてきました
地元に本社を持つ
京都府一の売上を誇るスーパーの社長が
亀岡のレジ袋有料化に
協力しようという声をかけてくれ
そして 亀岡市と協定を結んでくれたのです
まさにそれにより
多くの事業者が 一気に協力を表明し
そして国よりも 11ヶ月早く
レジ袋を有料にすることが できたのです
2019年8月
市民の高い環境意識に支えられ
この有料化がスタートし
それによって 市民は
エコバッグを持って買い物する行動
80%を超えてきたのです
私は 市民が意識の変わった瞬間
そのことを実感したのであります
事業者も 市民のその理解が広がることにより
条例も作れるのではないかというようなことが
叫ばれるようになってまいりました
私たちは レジ袋の有料化の次の
プラスチックレジ袋
提供禁止条例を制定するために
市民向けの説明会を
２カ月半で 30回以上開催し
市民の理解を広げていきました
そして 最終的に
各家庭に アンケートを取ったのです
その結果 ７割以上の市民が
条例に賛成をしてくれました
それによって 一気に
この条例の気運が高まったのです
しかし この時点で まだ事業者は
反対意見がたくさんありました
私たちはこのような中 市民に向けて
エコバッグを持つ 啓発事業をやる
「KAMEOKA FLY BAG Project 」を
やりました
これは環境と そして芸術とのコラボによって
亀岡盆地を飛ぶパラグライダーの
言うなれば
廃棄する生地をアップサイクルして
巨大エコバッグを作って
この駅前の環境事業の取り組みに
掲げたのであります
その後 これを切り開き
各々の部分を 切り取っていただき
スタッフの手により
世界に１個のエコバッグを作って
市民に持って帰っていただきました
今では そのエコバッグは
「HOZUBAG」というブランド名で
全国50カ所で
販売をさせていただいています
当時の環境大臣と面談が叶い
亀岡の「プラスチックごみゼロ宣言」の
取り組みを説明をし
「ぜひとも 国においても
有料化をしてほしい」
「できれば 紙袋も有料化してください」
そんな要望をいたしました
国がいち早く レジ袋の有料化を表明し
その取り組む過程の中で
コンビニエンスストアや
ファーストフード店の 全国店舗の事業者から
条例制定に対しても
これだけの理解があればできるのではないか
そういう声が聞こえてくるようになりました
私たちは 忘れもしません
全国初の取り組み
2020年3月24日にですね
亀岡市議会の本会議において
全ての議員の賛同をいただき
この条例が可決成立し 一定の周知期間を取り
2021年1月1日から
条例施行をしたのであります
もちろん そこには
コンビニエンスストアや
ファーストフード店についても 遵守いただき
違反すると 事業名を公表するという
罰則までつけた条例となったのであります
それに伴い
亀岡市民のエコバッグ持参率が
98.2％になりました
市民と事業者との取り組みが このような形で
レジ袋提供禁止条例のルールが
定着した瞬間であります
世界的なファストフード店
そしてファッションブランド店が
亀岡のお店から レジ袋をやめ
紙袋を有料にしてくれました
そして それを全国に２千店舗以上のお店に
広げてくれたのであります
まさに市民と事業者と行政の取り組みが
大きな成果を上げた瞬間であります
そのことも評価され 2020年7月
内閣総理大臣から 亀岡市は
「SDGs未来都市」に
認定をいただきました
そして 一部上場企業を含め
15の民間企業と
「かめおか未来づくり環境パートナーシップ」
を締結し
今 環境の取り組みを進めています
これらの一連のことが
実は 年間250回以上
テレビや新聞に 取り上げていただき
全国10万人の方々から
亀岡市に ふるさと納税を
していただくことになったのです
そして 亀岡の世界に誇れる
環境先進都市の取り組みが
実は地域経済をも
潤す形になったのであります
「志成最諦」
私の座右の銘となりました
この言葉は
一度志を立てて 事を起こすのであれば
少々難しく失敗しても 諦めることなく
最後までやり通すことで新たな道が開ける
これは松下幸之助さんから
私が学んだことであります
そして 亀岡市はこれから
市民と事業者の これからの取り組みを
全国の自治体に広げていこうと思っています
そして 日本が世界をリードする
環境先進国になることを期待をしています
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）